we're going to talk now about data and
privacy we live in an age where data is
quite simply a valuable resource
particularly our own individual personal
data and this is only going to increase
with the advance of new technologies and
Innovations so the big question in this
area is how do we keep our personal
information safe and what are those
companies and organizations using our
data doing to keep it safe plus there
are authorities as well to monitor this
activity how are they keeping us safe we
hand out so much personal information
and put it out there on the internet
don't we so it is a pertinent question
now and of course for future Generations
because people are getting online uh
younger quite frankly than we ever did
um so to talk about this I'm joined by
the information commissioner John
Edwards and by Crystal Palace footballer
Lee Nichol welcome to you both thank you
so much for coming down to our big event
here today
um there's so much going on there's so
many important issues in this field but
this is a particularly pressing one it
feels with so many young people getting
online now um
Lee I want to talk to you first about
your experience this has very personal
resonance with you because you were the
victim of intimate image abuse talk to
us about what happened
yes on 2019 I received the link on
Instagram that led to me opening and it
was a fail worth seven or eight videos
of me when I was 18 when I made no
looking back the wash decision of my
life to record myself in a very private
moment with another individual and
I found out about that when I was 23 so
the videos were five years old that I
completely forgot about I didn't know
they existed anymore in that moment when
I clicked on that link my life literally
Came Crashing Down and I've never
experienced pain shock
anything like it before no one can ever
prepare you for that moment
um and that moment I lost the most
expensive thing in my world and that was
my privacy and there was nothing that I
could have done about it because it got
so much attention it went viral
worldwide it was trending on websites
that you should never be trending on and
unless you want to
um it came with a lot of social media
abuse and that's all fell out there to a
dignity if anyone wants to unfortunately
find it they'll find it and
I think initially for the first six
months for me it was about surviving
um keeping myself here and present and
breathing it wasn't really about
anything else in life and
the most difficult moment within it all
was having to tell my family because
it's not just me that went through it
was my family my loved ones and
so this day that's the thing that
struggled with most because it wasn't
just a damage done to me it was the
Damage Done around me and my family my
friends worrying that I wouldn't survive
it because many people don't survive
this thing yeah
he went through personal trauma that you
will have to deal with for the rest of
your life you've been very honest about
this and you know you've come out of the
worst of it you feel but as you've been
very honest and saying it's something
that you and your loved ones have to
live with but since this happened to you
you've been on a learning curve because
as far as you know
these images these videos these these
personal that were on your personal
device you deleted them
but your iCloud was hacked and you know
the learning curve for you is that how
that happened because so many people
here today
um watching us online or on TV you know
we're very naive in that respect we have
all these pictures on our phone and we
know they go somewhere up there for
storage but you and on a learning curve
as to how this could happen how easy it
is to happen yeah I think for the vast
majority of people that this kind of
crime happens to there's an individual
responsible someone you know someone
they know of but for me it's so hard for
me to get my head around that that email
address that I set up in 2008 when I was
at school is the email address that
ended up ruining my life about 14 years
later and you're never taught that
especially when I was at school starting
up my first MSN account or Facebook
account
I never fought for one minute that email
address years and years and years later
would be the cause of my trauma so
I didn't know that once you delete
things off your device it's still there
somewhere it's the digital footprint
yeah like now when I say it sounds
ridiculous it sounds like common sense
but honestly back then no one told me
that make sure that you then sign onto
your iCloud on a different device to
then remove it and I wasn't aware of
two-factor authentication at the time
that gives you that extra security to
make sure no one can get into your
iCloud and that was probably the main
learning curve I had no idea that is
that he was still existed but the debts
and I'm sure that a lot of people
listening today will be like I've got a
picture that I would never want anyone
in the world to see it could be
something like a bikini picture it could
be your passport photo it could be
absolutely and I could be an innocent
photo of your children you just don't
want the wider world to see it and for
me to think that it's there somewhere
yeah it still blows my mind now it's a
really daunting thought I think for most
people and I'm going to ask um John a
question in just a moment but you have
all got QR codes so if you do want to
send a question into this panel please
scan that QR code and send us and for
those watching us elsewhere uh go to
Twitter hashtag Big Ideas live 22.
John where do you come into all of this
because
the problems that Lee has faced is
something that that you get involved in
as information commissioner what is it
that you do to help people likely and
everyone here stay safe online
thanks Sarah Jane I I first I just want
to say how
um how much I admire Lee and her bravery
in telling her story because it's not
easy and I think one of the things we've
got to get past in society is victim
blaming and the shame that people feel
when they are the victims of these
malicious actors who are taking
advantage of security flaws to steal our
most intimate moments that's
reprehensible
so at the information commissioner's
office we administer laws that are
intended to protect Lee and everybody
else in the community and their personal
data uh the most the one that people
will most know of is called the UK gdpr
it's the general data protection act and
it says that platforms and organizations
that hold data have to keep it secure uh
and they can only use it for the
purposes for which it was obtained and
they have to be transparent about those
and things like that so we deal with um
complaints
um the the matter the lead dealt with
that was a criminal matter that should
have been investigated by the police
um but people have rights also to get
data deleted uh when a platform should
no longer be holding it so we are also
committed to
trying to make the online environment
safer by
um by enforcing these security standards
we're trying to provide education in the
same way that Lee's doing today by
telling her story
we're also working with industry to make
the online services safer for children
and that's a really big thing for us so
we've got a a law called the age
appropriate design code we call it the
kids code but it says if you're pointing
uh Digital Services towards children and
children are likely to access your
services you've got to design your
service with privacy in mind as a
default so switch off location tracking
disable messages from people who aren't
contacts
um you know
make the the posts private by default so
it's stuff like that it's getting
organizations to think about how the
individuals could be harmed and to try
and avoid the kind of experience that
Lee's had yeah Lee I know you use the
bad experience you had for good use
because you talk to young people now
about the Perils of putting their
information online I mean every
everybody in this room will have put
their name address telephone number
email date of birth into a website
somewhere that's just how it works
what advice do you offer young people
because obviously that kind of data has
to be out there nowadays but when it
comes to their own very private data
pictures and who they talk to online
what message are you telling them
I think the obvious one for me would be
don't do it but I can say that because
I've made the mistake myself but I think
that's unrealistic it's 2022 so it's if
you are an individual and you're in a
relationship and you feel like this is a
big part of it it's about making sure
that you have got the correct things in
place to protect yourself and the free
main behaviors that I always speak to
and we at my company speak to other
people and clients and kids about is
being risk-averse being respectful and
being defensive and by those free
behaviors you won't often go wrong in
life because we can't control the
platforms and what they do in criminals
that are are looking to expose other
individuals but what what we can control
is control their own behavior and making
sure that we're not putting ourselves
too much at risk if you feel the need to
share an image for example take your
identity out of it if it's a really
crucial part to your relationship or
it's something you really really want to
do take your identity out of it because
then you're not dealing with public
humility and victim blaming and all of
those things so it's about being
defensive and not taking too many risks
in life and just always being a good
person for me John how prevalent is
hacking and the experience that Lee went
through because you know I've lost count
of the amount of times over the last
year I've had alerts saying that a
password I've used has been compromised
in a data leak and at one point it was
happening so often you know changing
passwords all the time just how easy is
it to hack and how exposed is our data
it's really hard to know how prevalent
hacking is but what we do know is that
the experience that Lee's had of a a
malicious third party
accessing a um an iCloud account those
are pretty those are relatively rare
most of the breaches occur by accident
and we see this every day businesses
failing to do the basics putting
everyone's email address in the CC field
rather than the BCC it's basic stuff
like that
um it's training staff to make sure that
if they get a suspicious email they
don't click on the links and this stuff
sounds so basic Sarah Jane but it's so
often neglected we find an organization
4.4 million pounds for failure to take
those basic steps which led to the
exposure of 113 000 employees sensitive
personal information
how much hard is your job going to get
because you know the Ico you're there to
protect people but you're also there to
promote data-led Innovation it's not all
bad you know the data can lead to to
great things as we're showcasing here
are Big Ideas live
so if collecting data is going to be a
more powerful tool just how tricky is
the protection element of it going to be
in the future well we're there really to
make sure that we can get as a society
and as individuals the benefits from the
wonderful Innovation and these tools
they're fantastic we all love our phones
we all love the online services but we
shouldn't have to compromise our privacy
for that yeah so I kind of reject the
language of trade-off can you have
Innovation or privacy we're entitled to
both so we're there to try and make sure
that businesses are enjoying the
benefits they're getting the Innovation
but they're doing it in a safe way that
respects our data in a way that
recognizes that it's not this Anonymous
data it's about a live person yeah uh
and that that person is entitled to
expect that their data is protected for
many people it would be an inconvenience
it will be having to change your
password having to call up your bank
having to do various different elements
like that but for you Lee it's as
serious as it gets you with a victim of
a crime so I'd be quite interested I
think a lot of people here would be as
well is how do you go about reporting
and dealing with a cyber crime because
if something happens to you in real
alive there's a clear set of structures
that everyone in this room will know you
go to the police you go through the you
know the the legal system what was that
experience like for you is it clear-cut
do enough people know about what to do
if they're a victim of hacking for
example in your case now what all I can
speak about is my one experience and it
it wasn't an easy procedure it wasn't
straightforward there was no step one
two three four my initial reaction was
actually to call 999 that was I thought
it was the biggest emergency in the
world to me at that point but when
I did speak to the place unfortunately I
don't think they have the resources or
the training in place to really handle
such a sensitive topic it's quite it's
not new but it's happening more and more
and more in our place don't have the
resources or the training to be able to
manage it effectively it took way too
long for the process to really start and
I must say the place for me they were
they were great emotionally but in terms
of the physical support there's not much
now I've learned there's not not much
any of us can do other than just take
the punches as they come and just accept
that it's now out there there isn't much
support that but authorities can offer
once it happens it's a we're reacting to
it
um but that's why I'm doing what I'm
doing now to try and help unfortunately
future victims have a more clearer
step-by-step process there is people out
there that can help get it removed from
from yoga girls from Safaris
but one thing I would say is these
things take time it does not happen
overnight it does not happen immediately
and my expectations where my videos are
out there I want them taken down with a
click of a button I'm three years on and
I've got people that manage my Google
and my social media platforms every week
to get them taken down and that costs
people a lot of money and the general
public don't have the kind of money that
it takes yeah I I mean John you are all
about holding those organizations and
companies to account you mentioned some
of the common mistakes they made but you
also are about protecting the individual
particularly the vulnerable about
equipping them with how to operate
safely online what is the biggest
mistake people make when it comes to
their own personal data
that's a really hard question let me
flip it um
there is an obligation that uh all
organizations have which is called data
minimization and that means they should
be looking at what information they're
collecting about people and only
collecting the minimum amount they need
to provide that person with the service
I think if as individuals we thought
about data minimization and only giving
out what was really necessary that would
be a help but I do think it's also
um it's a mistake to load the blame on
the users of this technology it's a it's
a mistake to say Lee didn't have
two-factor authentication and therefore
she's to blame
we need to be holding these technology
companies to account to ensure that they
are really thinking about what harm
could come from uh Bad actors using
their Technologies and designing in
features to ensure that those harms are
prevented
who needs to do more do you think Lee I
mean we've touched on it there haven't
we is it the big platforms the big
companies a lot of the excuses that I'm
sure you're well aware of John people
will say you know it's too complicated
it's too expensive it's too time
consuming a lot may not admit it affects
their bottom line what more needs to be
done do you think
I think there's there's two things we're
looking at we're looking at on websites
that exist that shouldn't exist and I
think
there's a responsibility that web hosts
have to not allow these websites in
particular to exist because they're just
created to cause harm and to publicly
shame individuals for their personal
life so you've got certain websites out
there that no one knows who runs them no
one knows who owns them and then you've
got social media there is an ongoing
conversation and has been for a long
long time and there's a a certain
platform that is getting worse at the
moment and it's a platform for 13 year
olds but if you go on the platform and
you're scrolling you come across
pornography and it just appears and that
speaking from someone who's scrolling
and I appear on on that platform and I
can't get it taken down they said it's
it doesn't reach any
it's me yeah I don't want myself and on
your on your platform and I don't think
any 13 year old should be scrolling on a
social media platform and and free
accessible illegal pornography or crime
appears on their on their site and we
agree with that absolutely and we're
doing a lot of work actually at the
moment enforcing the children's code
looking at video sharing platforms
social media gaming where children and
people under 13 should be able to enjoy
those safely without coming across that
kind of content and so we're actually
out there investigating those platforms
and finding it and taking action okay
and I've got a couple of questions from
the audience Jenny uh Jenny submitted a
question Jenny they are Jenny's at the
front if you want to stand up the um
microphone will find you here he comes
you've got to be faster with that boom
and Jenny what was your question for our
panel
a question for John
um do you think the much delayed Online
safety bill will give you adequate
powers to help in cases like Lee
thank you
um thanks for the question because it's
it's a really important one
um The Online safety bill has been
working its way through the law making
process and it's now going through
Parliament
um it will provide remedies for people
who are the victims of a harmful content
uh online and that's really important it
won't provide me with powers that law is
going to be administered by ofcom
and it's quite interesting though
because
the the the the line between content and
data is so blurred at times
recently uh there was a Coroner's
hearing into the tragic death of a young
woman called Molly Russell and the
coroner uh heard evidence about some of
the very traumatic content that she was
presented with now under the Online
safety legislation
that that content and whether it should
have been there it will be something
that ofcom can consider under that law
whereas the kind of use of personal
information the data that drove the
algorithms that presented more and more
harmful material to that young woman
that's data protection so we'll be
working really closely with ofcom to
make sure that legislation does what
it's intended to do and keeps people
safe online
thank you
great question and we've got one come in
on Twitter from Glenn who's watching he
says is legislation falling behind
technology when it comes to data and
privacy is it falling behind yeah
it's always it's always a race uh I
think the great benefit of our law that
this gdpr and the other Associated laws
is that the technology neutral Sarah
Jane so they're set at sort of high
level principles that gives them the
flexibility to adapt let me give you an
example we've recently had a look at um
some technology which is uh supposedly
able to test to tell what people's
emotional state is through Biometrics
and on the basis of that uh screen
people out from uh recruitments job ads
uh you know recruiting processes we've
looked at it we've got experts they say
it doesn't work it's nonsense so taking
that evidence we can say that that's
unlawful because it's disproportionate
it's not fair it's not delivering what
it's said on the box uh and it's making
an inappropriate use of of data and
that's brand new technology but the law
is capable of uh of still regulating
that okay they're connecting that race
then we'll say and just time for one
final question Lauren is in the audience
Lawrence do you want to stand up
Lauren stand up and show us where you
are out just at the front there perfect
and Lee you can answer this one Laura
what's your question
um so easy one was do 13 year olds
position
okay so do 13 year olds possess the
capacity to keep themselves online do
you think because you mentioned that as
an age um age bracket for social media
and various platforms I think 13 year
old year olds can do that
I think it comes down to families and
what they're comfortable with and I
think it depends
how open families are with each other
because adults know a little bit more
Believe It or Not than 13 year old kids
and I know that sometimes they're 10
year olds assume that they know more
than that the adults but I think there's
you need to be ready as a family and you
need to be willing to communicate about
online harms about trolling about
bullying
having the right Security on your if if
you can't put the rate Security on these
platforms to start with you're not ready
to be on social media if you can't have
your account on private message request
shut off hide your your phone name
because you're only 13 there's no need
to have your real name on these
platforms so no one should be able to
identify you so I think it comes down to
individual basis and depend on your
household but I do think it's still very
young to be making potentially big
decisions and posting things that could
come back to haunt you in 10 years time
whether it's slightly embarrassment
embarrassing silly comments that
unfortunately now we're seeing coming
back around and people being punished
for those yeah it's about being open And
discussing it as a family you talk to
your children about not talking to
strangers when they go out you know for
the day in town but not as many people
realize that you know online as well
there are dangers out there I know
you've got a second question but we
don't have time however do you want to
come and ask the panel when we come off
stage you can also don't okay Lauren
we'll do that for you um John Edwards
information commissioner Lee nickel
Crystal Palace footballer thank you so
much for talking today Lee in particular
for sharing your experience thank you so
much